Yanis cetera comfo
[Applause]
oh man I'm nervous okay
so first of all and I won't thank God
for blessing me with this amazing talent
I will didn't you know be this position
that I am today made whole so
[Music]
yeah yeah I won't thank God for putting
me in this immense position I am today
everything I do I do it through him and
I'm extremely place and Maria lessness
all I think God I won't take my team a
team first of all on take my teammates
he takes more than one person to win 16
games every time I walk to a locker room
I saw my teammates they were ready to go
to fight they were ready to go to war
with me
the last of their shoes they went out
there and they gave hundred percent I
don't think the coaching staff for them
ok I want take the coach there for
teaching us pushing us every day every
single day believing in us teaching us
what it takes to win I think I think the
front office the ownership for your ID
you know believe in me
I don't think the the front half is the
ownership for believing in me and I was
80 years old it is you know they allow
me to live this same trust me and I
don't think the City of Milwaukee I
don't think my country Greece and the G
of always supporting me you know back in
Greece when the wise the game is 5 a.m.
6 a.m. so they always stay up and watch
the games and said to me no message
support message in the deficit me and
the team and my family I won't think my
dad obviously you know my dad's nicer
with me but
[Music]
you know - two years ago in gonna have
to go in my head that I'm going I'm
gonna be the best player in the league
yeah I'm gonna do whatever it takes to
help my team win and I'm gonna win MVP
and every dealer I step on the floor
I was never mad and that motivates man
he pushed me to you know play hard and
move forward even though with my buddy
sword if you know man
I don't feel like playing I was gonna
show up and I was gonna do the right
thing
I wanna think my amazing not this you
know I love you guys
[Music]
I love you guys because you might like
to die even if you guys are my role
models man I look up to you guys thank
you for everything you guys do for me
and I won't take my my amazing mom an
amazing mom
[Music]
in my missing mom she's my hero she's
you know we always feel very kid you
know you don't see the future right and
you know if you have a good parent your
paris's sees the future for you and she
always saw the future in us you always
believed in her she was always there for
us
she the power - of this family you might
not even get my true hero
you're not true hero my agents you know
thanks for believing in me take for
motivating me thank you for staying off
my lanes when the season starts and you
guys don't bother me a lot and but you
know at the end of the day this is just
the beginning this is just the beginning
my goal is to win a championship as my
dad saw me you know always more and more
but never be greedy my goal is to win a
championship and you're gonna do
whatever it takes to make that happen
thank you guys
[Applause]
[Music]